-Our next guest
is a talented author
whose new novel "Assembly"
was published today.
Please welcome to the show
Natasha Brown.
Hello, Natasha. How are you?
-Hi, Seth. I'm really good,
thank you. How are you?
-I'm great.
So, this is very exciting,
and I'm wondering
if you have nerves,
because this book came out
a few months ago in the U.K.
It was obviously
very well-received.
Today, it's available
in the States.
Are you over the butterflies,
or are you excited
that a whole new group of people
gets to be introduced to it?
-I'm so excited to share it
with more people, I think.
It's definitely been
a bit terrifying
the last couple of months,
but it's so nice
to get a chance to bond
to readers over the book.
-It's also your first novel.
And, you know, that's an
impressive accomplishment enough
to have your first novel
be so well-received,
but was this always the novel
you were setting out to write
as your first endeavor?
-Not really, actually.
I think I went into it
not really knowing
what it was going to be.
And all I knew was
I wanted to explore
some of the ideas I'd been
reading about in nonfiction
to try and find a story
that would hopefully
bring them to life.
And I just sort of
immersed myself
in the world and the characters.
And when I saw
where it was going,
I just tried to follow it.
-And you had
a background in finance.
You did it for years.
The main character in this book
is a black British woman
in finance.
Yet it's -- I mean, how much
of it is autobiographical,
and how much of it is
just using your experiences
to create
a completely new person?
-Yeah, well, I think
we don't even really know much
about her as a person,
and that was something
I really consciously
wanted to do.
I didn't want this novel
to look at her.
I wanted to try and bring
the reader into her perspective
and look out at the world
that she was in.
So it definitely drew on kind of
people I've met,
things I've seen.
But I really tried to make sure
it was almost
an immersive experience
and tried to keep the details
about the narrator
out of the story.
-I did read
that there was a detail,
maybe I guess
to sort of show excess,
like, a very fancy high chair
that one of your friends
recognized
was in fact the fancy high chair
that she had.
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
I saw her high chair,
and a few months later,
when she read the manuscript,
I got a message saying,
"Is that my high chair?"
But I think she's happy
that it's in a book now.
-Okay, right.
It was worth every penny
if it can show up in a book.
So, this book talks about things
such as, you know, class
and racism and sexism,
immigration.
And yet at the core,
this narrator, I think,
feels disassociated
maybe in a way
that a lot of people from a lot
of different backgrounds feel.
Like, so, you have this
very specific point of view,
you know, based on
the narrator's identity.
But were you also aware
that you were writing, like,
I think, for me, ideas that are
really universal to all of us?
-I think absolutely. And
I think, you know, as a reader,
I've read sort of
the old English classics,
and I get totally
absorbed in them
and totally
feel for the characters
and understand
where they're coming from,
even if I've never been
in a horse and carriage
or anything like that.
And I felt that by
just really leaning into the
specifics of this woman's life
and trying to make it
as immersive
and believable as possible,
it could sort of help show the
universality in her experience.
-This is a super --
I read it so quickly.
It's not a long novel.
Have people been coming to you
saying, like,
"You left me wanting more,"
and is that, as a writer,
something you're happy to hear?
-[ Laughs ]
I think there's definitely been
the "I wanted more" response
and then also the slightly
sort of sheepish response
that it's kind of nice
to have a short book.
I'm definitely a fan
of short books, too, sometimes.
-It is -- You feel
embarrassed to say it,
but I am definitely
a fan of short books,
and thank you for writing one.
[ Both laugh ]
I also wanted to ask where --
Because I think this is the
thing that's most fascinating
to people, when they meet
someone who's written a novel,
when do you find yourself
most productive?
-So, I'm one of those
really annoying morning people.
I get up at like 5:00 or 6:00
in the morning,
go down to the kitchen,
make coffee,
and hopefully to get one
or two really productive hours,
and it just tapers off
from then.
-Well, that's a good way
of going about things.
And I wanted -- Now I just
want to confirm a rumor.
And I'm really hoping it's true.
-[ Laughs ]
-I have heard --
First of all, anytime
anyone across the pond
watches our show,
I'm very happy.
I'm very flattered.
Is it true that you watch
"Corrections"?
-I do. I opted into
"Corrections."
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you very much.
Well, thank you so much.
We're always --
You're far nicer than
what I expected from a jackal.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, congratulations so much
on the book.
It really is
such a wonderful read,
and it's lovely meeting you.
-Thank you so much.
Lovely to meet you.
-"Assembly" is available now
wherever books are sold,
but please remember
to support local
and independent bookstores.